[موسيقى]
اولا الشديد اليوم هو عوده حكومه نتنياهو
للسلطه
شاهدنا خلال فتره حكم نتنياهو السابقه
تصعيد في العمل داخل اراضينا عمليه اغتيال
العلماء الايرانيين قصف
حاولت تفجير مهاجمه منشات نوويه ومنشات
تصنيع صواريخ هذه الامور توقفت ما حكومات
بنت
وحكومات او وسط يسار اليوم عوده حكومه
اليمين ان نشهد هذا التطور
[موسيقى]
الامر الاخر هو الساعه المتعلقه بالتحصيب
هناك تقدم كبير في عمليه التخصيب
اليورانيوم من جانب ايران في وقت لا
كاميرات مراقبه
تتبع ما يجري داخل المنشات التخصيب النووي
الايراني وبالتالي هناك مستوى القلق باتك
كبير جدا في اسرائيل ودول الاوروبيه في
موضوع هذا
الملف النووي الايراني
[موسيقى]
الصواريخ البلاستيكيه هي اداه توصيل
الرؤوس النوويه مستقبلا لايران وبالتالي
الخطوه التاليه لبرنامج النووي الايراني
هو تصنيع راس حربي يوضع على صواريخ
بالستيوب
[موسيقى]